In his
State of the Union
address, President Biden accused some
but not all Republicans of wanting
to cut Social Security and Medicare.
Some Republicans want Medicare
and Social Security sunset.
I'm not saying it's a majority.
You can see Kevin McCarthy there
shaking his head
that led
Republicans in the chamber to bo
President Biden and call him a l
The president did not
name names on Tuesday,
but yesterday he was in Wisconsi
and he identified
the Republican lawmakers
that he was referencing
reading directly from their prop
Well,
I'm glad you said
I got his brochure right here.
I has a plan.
Here's what he says in his plan.
Let me get over it up here.
Sorry.
He says
all federal legislation sunsets
every five years.
If the laws were keeping,
Congress can pass it again.
Social
Security, Medicare, Medicaid.
The president
there was referring to Senator
Rick Scott.
And today he is going to Senator
Scott home state of Florida,
where he's
set to give a speech on Social S
and Medicare in Tampa.
So joining us now for his perspe
is that Senator Senator Rick
Scott of Florida. Thank you so m
For joining us this morning.
I think my first question has to
given the fact that the presiden
is now using this as an attack l
Was it a mistake to propose this
No.
First off,
nobody believes that
I want to cut Medicare
or Social Security. I've never s
I've never said in that same pla
I said Congress aides to once a
tell the American public
how they're going to make sure
those programs don't go bankrupt
because in the verge of bankrupt
And here's a difference.
Screen Joe Biden to me,
I have never proposed it
in 1975 he has a bill a sunset b
and it says it requires every pr
to be looked at virtually at lea
every four years.
Not not just cost but worthiness
And Kaitlyn
he said when I argued that
we should freeze federal spendin
I meant so security as well
I met Medicare Medicaid
veterans benefits.
I meant every single
solitary thing in government.
So here's the difference.
I've never proposed it.
He proposed it in the bill
and he fought for it.
Year after year after year.
You're talking
about what
he proposed back
in 1975 is almost 50 years ago.
But you have said
he's twisting your words.
But isn't that the same thing
that what you're proposing now,
what you rolled out last summer.
Mine says mine says clearer
my size clearer.
You know,
if it's worth
keeping, we're going to keep it
in his case.
Maybe he proposed a bill
that just sunset everything.
I've I've never done that.
I've been very clear.
I am not for cutting
Social Security, Medicare.
And that quote says he's clearly
He proposed a year
after year after year
to reduce Medicare and Social Se
year after year.
I've never done that.
I don't believe in that.
I think we've got to preserve
those benefits.
You say he's twisting your words
but he said, quote,
Some Republicans want Social Sec
and Medicare to sunset.
You wrote,
I suggested
following all federal legislatio
sunsets in five years.
If a law is worth keeping,
Congress can pass it again.
You are Republican.
Medicare and Social Security
are federal legislation.
And you said it's worth keeping.
Congress can pass it again.
But but no one.
I don't think has confidence
that if something comes up for a
every five years,
that Congress is going to be abl
to make sure it stays,
especially something that
vitally important to so many
I've been clear.
I'm not going to do it in Congre
Let's remember
just what, a few months ago,
all Democrats voted in Joe Biden
signed a bill to cut $280 billio
out of Medicare to $80 billion
cut out of Medicare.
That's not true.
Senator, we talked about this.
The other day
when you were on the program
that that was passed
in the Inflation Reduction Act.
Reducing drug
spending is not
cutting benefits to Medicare.
Okay.
Let me just read you something
Jake Tapper said.
This is back
when Republicans are proposing
reducing the cost of Medicaid.
He said, Jake
Tapper said, I know the Trump
administration is excited
that Medicaid will go back to th
where they have more control
and can experiment and be more e
But without question,
$880 billion is a cut.
So he said, is it a cut?
When you
when Republicans do it, but not
when Democrats proposed saying
what you're
referencing Senator,
I looked into this
because we talked about it the o
And even the senior VP for a AAR
government affairs said
this has been fact checked
repeatedly and shown to be a lie
In fact,
this bill saves Medicare
nearly $300 billion
by lowering the price of drugs.
Our drug companies, only
drug companies would say
that saving people money is a ba
But what about what Jake Tapper
I mean, for Jake Tapper
said was Jake Tapper
due to the Inflation Reduction A
I don't think he was.
He was referring to a reduction
in costs in Medicaid.
So that's
how does it have to do with what
what Democrats passed last fall?
This is about lowering allowing
to negotiate the prices of drugs
Basically,
if you've budgeted and you've go
and you go and buy a card, it no
costs $12,000.
That doesn't mean you only have
It means you just did
not spend all $15,000.
Right.
Caitlin, two things.
First off, what they did
this fall is going to reduce
life saving drugs.
But the Republicans propose
was not a reduction in Medicaid
It was a cut in.
Jake Tapper said that is a cut.
So CNN says it's not a cut
if Democrats do it.
It is a kind of Republicans.
So I mean, what else can you say
I mean, that's exactly what you'
You know, I see what you're sayi
How, you know,
have you talked to Jake Tapper?
Why did he say
he was a kind of Republicans do
Senator I'm
not sure that what Jake Tapper
said is relevant to what
this particular point is,
what you're claiming
about the cost of drugs costing
and therefore being a cut.
Everyone else has said that is n
It's been fact-checked multiple
And they say that that's simply
But okay, so if they
if the Senate
did the same fact checkers
go back and look at what Jake
Tapper said.
I mean I mean,
I don't get
I don't get why
if one party proposes efficienci
that's a cut.
But if the other party does, it'
not a cut.
I mean,
unless reducing cut to $90 billi
the same is cutting benefits.
Correct.
Okay, Wolf,
look,
it actually is
what they did
last fall is going to reduce
life saving drugs in life saving
I understand
you're saying as an impact on dr
That is different, though,
than saying
that they cut Medicare
when they're saving money on the
of what those drugs cost to Amer
Okay.
But and then why didn't Jake Tap
said that?
$88 billion cut Medicaid is a cu
I'm sorry, Senator.
I don't think that's the defense
that you think it is.
But I want to go back to this po
in your proposal
on Medicare and Social Security,
because you're saying that that
what your intention was
with your proposal last fall.
But even Republicans,
it came back and came out agains
including Senator Mitch McConnel
who said
we will not have as part of our
a bill that raises taxes
on half the American people and
Social Security and Medicare wit
even within five years, even Rep
If that's what you were suggesti
So let's first off, I think I cu
more than almost any Republicans
Taxes and fees 100 times as gove
I've never
supported a tax or fee increase.
That's why number
two and I won't support any.
Number two is
I've been clear,
I will not reduce
Social Security, Medicare benefi
All right.
I been clear
and I was clear in my plan
that Congress needs to fix Medic
I mean, make sure that Medicare
and Social Security survive.
I said we got to tell them
what we're going to do.
All the recipients,
how we're going to do it.
Does that sound like somebody
that wants to cut
Medicare and Social Security?
But in contrast, we have a presi
that proposed it
time and time time again.
And we've got Democrats that hav
just in the last few months.
Senator, if that wasn't your int
why didn't you put an exemption
for Medicare and
Social Security in your plan?
Well, I was I was very clear.
It's my plan. I wrote it.
I've told people all along
what I believe.
I fought for Medicare and Social
the entire time I been up here.
And I'm going to continue
to fight for it.
And look, Joe Biden has proposed
and he wants to say I have done
No, actually, did I oppose it in
I didn't.
I wrote to fight it. I wrote the
I mean, you didn't write your pl
I wrote the plan.
And I've been clear about it.
Anybody asked me what I meant.
I've been very clear.
Nobody believes
that I have a goal of reducing
I don't know any Republicans
that want to cut Medicare
Social Security benefits,
but I know Democrats that have d
and you've got a president
that proposed it time and time a
Okay. So let's live in reality.
Let's we are living in reality.
And let's say your plan passes
and this happens
and then every five years,
it's up for a vote.
We're watching
what's happening with the debt
ceiling right now
and how some
Republicans in your party
are trying to use it as leverage
So wouldn't it basically
subject Social Security
and Medicare
to these potential extortion tac
by Republicans down the road?
We have 31 half
trillion dollars of the debt.
If you care about preserving
Medicare and Social Security,
we will figure out how to start
living within our means
because there is come
there will be a day in time
that we can't borrow more money.
I want to make sure we balance o
and preserve
Medicare and Social Security.
I've been clear all along.
So what I want to do
is get rid of wasteful programs
that we never review up here.
They just they just we they get
Nobody ever looks at them.